The clearest dynamic we have to deal with
as people thinking about
the future of the city,
is the polarization of
the public conversation.
You know, the lack of collective idea
of what the city is for.
And we think that the streets,
that kind of gigantic untapped resource
of open space in cities really,
is a place where we can really work
to transform something that's
been reserved for motorcars,
into something that's an amenity
for the whole population.
Hopefully, in a way that can be scalable
to the whole country and beyond.
As countries wonder how to meet
their carbon neutral promises,
many have also begun to question
the future of our cities.
A popular model is the 15-minute city.
It's a vision of a
decentralized urban area
where your daily needs are
within a quarter hour walk
or bike from your home.
It promises to cut greenhouse emissions
and boost livability.
But while Paris works on neighborhoods
with a 15-minute radius,
and Barcelona explores a similar idea
dividing areas into nine block chunks,
Sweden is taking the hyperlocal
concept one step further.
The one minute city idea, of course,
uses a buzzy sounding phrase to talk about
the even more local than
the hyperlocal scale.
You know, the street exactly
outside your front door,
or outside the door of
a cafe or a business,
and how that can be transformed
to make additional amenity
space, to make public spaces
that didn't exist before.
This is the Street Moves project,
and it allows communities
to become architects
of their own streets layouts.
It's led by two national
government agencies,
ArkDes, the national center
for architecture and design,
And Vinnova, the Swedish government's
national innovation agency.
I think there's a sort of
implicit critique in the project
that questions residents and citizens role
in planning processes.
We have now these very large
scale formal planning processes
in most Western countries
that make it very hard
for individual citizens to influence
the outcome of urban change.
But we know that citizens
have really, really
strong opinions especially about
their immediate environment.
So that method of involving citizens
with their hyperlocal,
extremely expert knowledge
on their environment, but
getting that out of their heads
and putting out on the table for designers
but also for agencies, national
agencies and municipalities,
we think there's something
really, really valuable in that.
Unlike the 15-minute city concept,
the Street Moves model isn't
about offering every feature
of a city at a hyperlocal level.
Instead, it turns patches of pavement
outside our front doors
into critical connecting
spaces for communities.
Through workshops and consultations,
residents can control how
much street space is used
for parking and how much
is used for anything else
they can think of.
It's already been rolled
out experimentally
at four sites in Stockholm,
with three more cities about to join up.
The prototypes were
designed by Lundberg design,
an industrial design
firm here in Stockholm.
And the prototype that exists
is a kind of deployable system
which runs on three simple tracks,
which can easily be laid
down on the streets.
And then sort of cassettes
or sections of timber
are laid on top of them.
And those sections, they fit together
and create a kind of
boardwalk which can be leveled
with the pavement, of course.
And different kinds of elements
can be integrated into them.
Be it seating, opportunities for planting,
cycle storage, electric, scooter storage,
and later, many, many other things.
When you make something
in three dimensions
by a designer who's skilled
at making something beautiful,
intriguing, different in
a material in this case
that's not often seen on
the streets in timber,
it becomes a talking point.
Sweden has committed its cities
to becoming carbon neutral by 2045,
making a project like Street Moves,
that de-emphasizes car use,
more of a feasible prospect.
But that's not all that
Street Moves wants to address.
Of course, the transformation
that needs to come to our cities
because of the need to
decrease our carbon use,
is the most urgent driver for
all of the transformations
that are coming, especially
in Swedish cities.
But we use that cover sometimes,
and we use that huge undeniable momentum
to also have other conversations.
And I think it's no
accident and no coincidence
that alongside the ecological
driven transformation
that's coming, there's
also a socially driven one.
Be it Black Lives Matters, be it Me Too,
be it large scale citizen led movements
that are bringing new dynamics
to the public conversation.
That creates new demands for the city.
And I think everybody's
starting to realize,
you know, the ecological
transformation that needs to come,
is just as much a cultural
project as it is technical.
Street Moves ultimate goal is ambitious.
To rethink and makeover
every street in Sweden
over the next decade.
But while this kind of
grand transformation
might appear to only work
for a country like Sweden,
Long and the Street
Moves team are confident
the concept can cross borders.
I think the future of scaling up
this kind of project internationally,
will be about using the talent
in those individual spaces
for what they're good at.
In Sweden, we have great
skill in industrial design
so that kind of modularity,
the materials, and so on,
really, really good at that.
In another country, it
might be a completely
other set of skills.
You know, it might be that the designers
take more of a lead on
the public conversation
than they might do here in Sweden.
In the end, what I believe in,
is that the extraordinary talent
that is around the world
in design and architecture,
can play a massively bigger
role than it already does
in that public conversation,
in generating new ideas
for how we use our city public spaces.